finding a very tight group of people
around you
that can share some of that burden the
recruitment mentors podcast
is proudly sponsored by vincerie who are
weaponizing recruiters
through tech and the award-winning sauce
breaker who are transforming the way
recruiters
work yeah once you go past 15 people
you know you can't be you can't
necessarily be
on top of everyone every single day to
give them support and you also need to
blend
i suppose the individual's coming into
your business you can't you can't
continue to hire people
at a mid to senior level you have to
start to train your own i suppose you
know
what what limited our growth in terms of
the next location
there was a big trust thing there's a
big massive trust thing for me
it is then trying to find did you grow
like well sometimes
there is a six-month transition or a
transition period where it's like
you just have to as you said get out of
your own way and you might
not really know what you're doing you
had a million
a million different thoughts going
through your mind about the different
challenges
and i suppose where it was really useful
working with simon
was you you you walk in
cluttered and you look out with
a clarity clear idea of what you're
gonna do